we want to show you why officials say
the next few weeks are so important it
took 67 days for the worldwide number of
reported cases to reach a hundred
thousand but just 11 days to reach 200
thousand and just four days to go to
three hundred thousand that is why there
is such high concern in hot spots all
across the United States including right
here in New York City and that's where
we find our lead national correspondent
David Beck know who joins us from his
New York City apartment David good
morning is New York getting the help it
needs from Washington Tony they are but
the governor says it's not enough and
you're about to sense his frustration
the governor saying look federal
government you're sending me stuff but
what you're sending me isn't matching
the urgency of the emergency the
governor is trying to convince the
federal government we are the worst of
where it is right now here in New York
cases are doubling every three days and
it's to the point now where the White
House told people yesterday if you left
New York recently to go anywhere in the
country you should self quarantine for
14 days immediately we remain deeply
concerned about New York City and the
min New York metro area that is because
more than half of the nation's new
coronavirus cases are being found right
here crowded subway cars may have
accelerated the spread
New York's governor says FEMA gave the
state 400 ventilators to that he said
this am I going to do with 400
ventilators when I need 30,000 you
picked the 26 thousand people who are
going to die because you only sent 400
ventilators the governor now projects
that the state will need up to 140,000
beds with an additional 40,000 ICU beds
across the river from New York at Holy
Name Medical Center in New Jersey
the chief infectious disease specialist
says his hospital has just 10
ventilators and barely enough for now
the mayor of Los Angeles says New York
could be a preview of what's to come we
are anywhere from about 6 to 12 days
behind what we are seeing in New York
City
and now to Louisiana cases are growing
faster there than nearly any other place
in the world they now have more than
13-hundred which per capita puts them
behind New York and Washington state
Louisiana's governor asked the President
to declare the state a major disaster
area and President Trump has the virus
took the life of a claim Tony winning
playwright Terrence McNally
he had pre-existing conditions he was a
lung cancer survivor with COPD he died
at 81 on president Trump's order nine
thousand natural garden have mobilized
around the u.s. troops in Charleston
West Virginia were delivering supplies
to hospitals back in New York kovat 19
has infected one of New York City's
finest 27 year old NYPD officer
Christine Galgano now her case is unique
because she also suffers from lupus and
because of that she is already taking
hydroxychloroquine we spoke to her by
phone that is a medication that they are
trying out to see if it can also help
people with kovat they're having my dose
as well to see if it's helping and so
far I've gotten through all of these
symptoms fairly quickly
officer Gaga knows mother was also
diagnosed with kovat 19 she is at home
and she is not doing as well as her
daughter 177 NYPD officers had tested
positive for kovat before I toss it back
I want you to know that we're getting
word this morning out of Atlanta where
the mayor there says they are at
capacity with their ICU beds in the city
and she expects that sometime soon they
may have to start using a field hospital
of sorts so I know the times thank you
very much David